foreign
[Music]
as of recording I'm about 150 hours into
tears of the Kingdom I've completed the
main story found all the light roots and
shrines did most of the side quests and
I think I got most if not all of the
armor sets the only thing I skipped
almost entirely is finding korok seeds
because I'm not a masochist with most of
the game's core content in the rear view
mirror I'm finally ready to talk about
lore however from what I've been able to
gather a significant amount of people
are not quite done with the main story
and even purposely stalling the story
progression because they aren't ready
for the game to end just yet there's
something I can totally get behind so I
think it's in everyone's best interest
if we start out small as such I've
compiled 10 lore secrets and details
which are more or less disconnected from
the main story like side content
references to past entries or the lore
behind a certain character item or
location things like that of course I
cannot talk about lore without avoiding
spoilers altogether so for your
convenience here's a list of notable
things that will be featured in the
video if any of these aspects are too
much of a spoiler for you at this this
moment I recommend coming back later so
with that said let's get into it
[Music]
let's kick things off with the biggest
and in my opinion the most interesting
piece of lore on the list the true
nature and possible origins of the gibdo
tears of the Kingdom puts a very
different spin on the gibdo compared to
previous titles where they are more or
less just bandaged up corpses akin to
the classic mummy from pop culture while
they do still have humanoid features
their design and behavior in tears of
the Kingdom also has characteristics of
that of insects like their vertical
pincer-like mouths weird pulsating neck
thing and most notably the fact that
some of them have wings reminiscent of
that of a moth or butterfly they fly now
they fly now sorry I I just I had to put
that in we learned that the gift though
that wander above ground emerged from
these giant mushroom-like structures
which the game's protagonists refer to
as hives these hives seem to be largely
responsible for them gaining access to
the surface from below ground which is
where they are most commonly found
seeing as the gypto were not present in
breath of the wild we can assume that
their most recent appearance is
connected to ganondorf's Magic in some
way in particular the emergence of Queen
gypto yes they actually have a queen in
this game in fact Ganondorf flat out
tells you that the bosses of Tears of
the Kingdom's dungeons are his servants
who he allegedly created or resurrected
to cause Mayhem in Hyrule in the case of
Queen Gip though she is confirmed to be
responsible for the massive Sandstorm
that envelops Gerudo town and during her
boss fight she is also shown to be in
control of the hives despite all of this
there are hints that the gibdo are not
only more than just insects and still
have some connection to the undead like
in the older games but also that they
have possibly existed independently of
ganondorf's rise in influence first is
the fact that we can find fossilized
High lives inside caves these hives look
ancient they have seemingly turned to
stone and are no longer active yet there
are still some gibdo in their vicinity
and who knows how long these have been
down here but by far the most compelling
piece of evidence is a passage from an
old Legend described by a member of the
yiga the yigaf build bases all across
hyrule's depths and in each and every
one of them you'll find a notebook
containing some information about their
plans research and so on the notebook in
question tells the story of an ancient
Gerudo treasure which goes like this
quote under the side of the Arbiter in
the darkness of the Subterranean depth
lies a great treasure whosoever seeks
this treasure must overcome their fear
as they will be met by a Vortex of the
Wrath of the executed unquote so let's
break this down real quick the site of
the Arbiter mentioned here is clearly
referring to the arbiter's ground a
location which has been the subject of
many theories ever since the previous
title it's a reference to the fourth
dungeon in Twilight Princess a vast
Coliseum in the Gerudo desert originally
a place of worship for the Gerudo it is
that when the Hylian seized control of
the arbitrus grounds during the war with
Ganondorf and his people they turned it
into a prison and execution site for
hyrule's most wanted in fact it's where
the failed execution of Ganondorf
himself took place in the story while
the arborist grounds we see here shares
little to no resemblance to the one from
Twilight Princess making a connection
between the two difficult to prove tears
of the Kingdom shows that there is more
to this place more specifically its
connection to the depths right below the
arbitus grounds is a place called The
Gerudo underground cemetery and it's
clear that the legend spoken of in the
yiga notebook is referring to this
location it is right below the side of
the Arbiter and does indeed have a
treasure hidden inside one of the tombs
here moreover the cemetery is absolutely
crawling with gibdo which is most likely
what the so-called Wrath of the executed
is referring to executed of course
implies that the gibdo are in fact
Undead in some way the reanimated
remains of former prisoners who were
punished and killed for their crimes
most likely by the ancient Gerudo while
it may seem odd that they would take on
the shape of an insect-like being it's
actually not uncommon in the Zelda
series that the deceased take on all
kinds of different forms after death
from harmless or vengeful spirits to
physical monsters like style enemies
redettes and more it all depends on how
they died or why they were brought back
for example if there's some sort of
curse involved there's another location
in tears of the Kingdom that reinforces
the idea that the gibdo were originally
prisoners who were perhaps killed a long
time ago an ancient Gerudo prison found
inside a sinkhole near Gerudo town this
location has clearly been abandoned for
thousands of years and yet we find gibdo
here inside prison cells prison cells
which in some cases are sealed shut and
have no way in or out who knows how long
these have been down here stuck inside
their cells unable to find peace one
final feature that's worth mentioning is
that in a lot of cases the gibdo have
arrows or various types of weapons
sticking out of them like swords and
Spears even the ones down in the prison
in fact some parts of the prison are
littered with arrows so could these be
hints to the method of execution
whatever the case may be it's a solid
reminder to always stay on the grudo's
good side
foreign
of the deceased very tearful I know
here's a little nod to breath of the
wild and Hyrule Warriors age of Calamity
in the previous game we found a pile of
rocks atop Mount Hialeah on the great
plateau in the name of the in-game model
as well as creating a champion confirmed
that this is the grave of the king and
I'm not talking about King furry over
here but King Rome boss faramas Hyrule
the last king of Hyrule who was among
the many casualties of the Calamity and
moves on to the afterlife in the true
ending of the game before that he can
even be seen visiting his own grave in
spirit form when revisiting the side in
tears of the Kingdom we find a large
two-handed sword stuck in the ground
here the sword is a royal Claymore which
in age of Calamity is the King's weapon
of choice it's a nice little callback
and while the game doesn't tell us who
left the sword here I'd like to think
that it was Zelda it would only make
sense that she would have visited her
father's grave after the events of the
previous game and subsequently left his
favorite weapon here to honor his memory
next we have something that's not so
much a lore Revelation but instead just
a neat little detail the torch link and
zeldar are seen varying during the
opening segment and subsequently falls
into the abyss alongside Zelda can
actually be found in the game I won't
spoil the how when and where but you can
in fact revisit this exact spot at some
point and when you do you'll come across
a lone torch laying at the very bottom
of the chasm again it doesn't have any
massive lore implications but I do think
it's cool that they took the effort to
include a small detail like this
especially considering that most people
probably didn't even notice or remember
the torch falling down since the focus
is on Link and Zelda
[Music]
when you sleep at one of the Stables you
are given the choice between a regular
bed or a millennia bed if you choose the
latter you'll not only wake up with
extra hearts and stamina but you also
get a visit in your dreams from the
horse God Melania and receive telepathic
messages from them Millennia is as their
title suggests a god-like entity who
watches over the many horses that roam
the kingdom and even has the ability to
bring them back from the afterlife one
of the messages you can receive from
Millennia while lodging at the Stables
involves a new species of animal which
weren't present in breath of the wild
the dondons which are awesome if only
for the fact that it's my first name
repeated twice an NPC states that these
creatures were discovered recently by
none other than Princess Zelda herself
and at so far only five of them are
known to exist funnily enough Zelda is
seen riding one of these animals in the
2019 footage which was unfortunately
scrapped for the finished game Millennia
reveals that the dondans have not only
existed since ancient times but that
they are in fact distant ancestors of
the current day horses if this is true
then I gotta say Evolution works in
mysterious ways in Hyrule then again
this is the same Series where fish
people evolved into birds in just a few
centuries so nothing too surprising I
guess
[Music]
next is a detail that could give us a
bit more insight into some of the
history of the ancient Chica and their
technology from 10 000 years ago those
who are familiar with the last game will
no doubt have noticed that most of the
Chic attacks seen in breath of the wild
has all but disappeared which
unfortunately isn't really touched upon
it's just gone now with little to no
explanation so we have to assume that
they got rid of it or repurposed it in
some way in the Years following the
victory over Calamity Ganon which not
only includes the Divine beasts
Guardians chica towers and regular
shrines but even the iconic Shrine of
Resurrection the starting point of the
previous Adventure when link had been
recovering from his near-death
experience for close to a century in the
present day all traces of the shrine of
Resurrection are gone the floor ceiling
and walls have been completely stripped
and it just looks like a natural cave at
this point the only thing that remains
and calls back to the shrine's unique
properties is a puddle of water which
when entered slowly heals you it's the
same effect as the various Hot Springs
found across Hyrule in fact the water
inside the shrine seems to be warm as
well as evident from the Steam and
Bubbles rising up however there's one
major difference between the water
inside the resurrection cave and the hot
springs which brings us to hyrule's
depths in a video I made quite a long
time ago I argued that there might be
volcanic activity below the hebra
mountains because despite being one of
the coldest places in the game there are
multiple Hot Springs present here the
only other region in breath of the wild
where we found Hot Springs was on Death
Mountain and of course here it made
perfect sense given that it's a literal
volcano but how can a hot spring exist
in a place with such a frigid climate
unless something is heating these Waters
up somehow and lo and behold tears of
the Kingdom confirms that this is indeed
the case in the depths right below every
hot spring in hebra is an active magma
flow which further emphasizes the
relationship between the depths and the
surface above however the same
explanation cannot be applied to the
shrine of Resurrection as far as we know
there's no heat source to create a hot
spring here but there is something else
beneath the shrine that could explain
the water's healing properties as we saw
previously with the arbitus grounds and
the Gerudo underground Cemetery many
noteworthy locations on the surface have
something of interest in the depths
right below them and the same goes for
the shrine of Resurrection in the vast
expanse of hyrule's Underworld there's a
total of four similar locations known as
Wellsprings three of which correspond to
the springs of power wisdom and courage
found on the surface however a fourth
one exists right below where the shrine
of Resurrection used to be and is called
the Wellspring of Revival the water
inside these Subterranean Springs have
the same healing effect as the hot
springs including the small puddle
inside the resurrection cave now it's
made obvious that the structures found
in the Underworld predate the events
from 10 000 Years Ago by a pretty wide
margin after all they fit the
architectural style of the zonai and the
zonai existed long before Ganondorf even
entered the scene let alone Calamity
Ganon this could mean that the ancient
chica despite never mentioning it in
breath of the wild either knew about the
existence of the depths or at the very
least were aware that certain spots
around Hyrule had unique properties thus
the location of the shrine of
resurrection's construction was not just
a random choice but because there was
already something here that piqued their
interest and would serve as the bay
basis for this medical facility they may
have discovered that the water here has
special healing effects something they
were able to tap into and amplify with
their technology to restore even the
most severe injuries
since we're on the topic of the depths
we might as well linger here for a bit
longer and cover some other details
about it so here's a few interesting
accounts from the yiga about their
experiences and observations inside the
underworld it comes to light that the
yigas interactions with the supernatural
elements of the depth differ quite a bit
from Link's experiences for example they
are unable to approach pose let alone
collect them like link does one member
describes that they do witness strange
ethereal lights but that when they try
to get closer the lights disappear it
makes them question if they are perhaps
just another species of firefly which
are abundant down here why do pose
disappear when the yiga try to approach
is not explained but it could have
something to do with their evil nature
or purity of their hearts in some way
ever since breath of the wild it's been
made clear that different people will
have different experiences with beings
who are classified as Spirits for
example link and kids who are of a
certain age can see the dragons whereas
most adults are completely oblivious to
them same goes for the spirits of the
forest who can also only be seen by
specific individuals and thank God
because the stuff we are doing to these
poor creatures is not for the faint of
heart the yiga also briefly elaborate on
the ghostly Shadows seen atop these Rock
piles or rather the lack thereof because
it becomes apparent that the yiga cannot
actually see these shadowy figures and
instead all they see is a weapon
floating in midair there's a lot to
discuss and theorize about these shadow
ghosts in the future but for now it's
interesting to know that these figures
don't actually make themselves known to
everyone another account from one of the
clan members shares an eerie detail
about the bargainer statues the entities
who inhabit these statues explain that
they help lost souls find their way into
the Afterlife they will trade all sorts
of items and armor sets in exchange for
post Spirits link has collected in the
underworld in that sense they seem
friendly however one yiga soldier paints
a more Sinister picture of the
bargaining statues they claim that when
some of their fellow clan members got
close they had their souls stolen from
them which from what I understand means
that they were essentially killed by the
statue but how and why is a mystery it's
quite a fascinating revelation because
the statues themselves emphasize that
when they help lost souls they make no
distinction between good or evil as this
is a quote futile perspective of
narrow-minded beings but I guess they
don't pass the same judgment on the
living and will steal your soul if
you're not worthy of an audience with
them it's a good thing link is the
chosen one or else his quest to save the
world would have been cut short
unexpectedly
so you may have noticed that some of the
monsters inside the depths are mining
for zonite this precious resource which
is predominantly found in hyrule's depth
can be processed into various types of
energy cells that fuel the Zona
technology as such the yiga who have a
vested interest in the zonai tech are
also scouring the Underworld for zonite
at first it may seem like the monsters
and the yiga are working towards the
same goal after all they are both on the
side of the Demon King but this doesn't
appear to be the case as one of their
notebook States quote it appears that
some of the monsters in the area have
been mining for or particular to the
depth our fellow yiga found them working
in large numbers around mineral deposits
and even carrying these oars but why
could the ore have some special use
unquote there's also various accounts of
the yiga actively trying to avoid
monsters so they are definitely not on
friendly terms despite being on the same
side it appears that the monsters are
operating independently of the yiga and
it makes you wonder why they would be
interested in these minerals to begin
with after all monsters don't utilize
zonai technology G like the yigadu so
there must be something else motivating
them to mine for zoneite which brings us
to the last observation by the yiga for
this video they mentioned that the
monsters in the depths are different
from the ones in the surface in that
they never seem to sleep of course
there's no sunlight down here and thus
no perception of night and day but I
would imagine that even monsters need
some shut eye once in a while but
apparently not down here which probably
has something to do with the fact that
with the exception of the frocks who
seem to be native to this environment
all monsters in the depths are infected
with malice or Gloom I should say
seriously why they change the name it's
so confusing anyway the Gloom seems to
give Monsters the ability to go on
forever without ever getting tired which
on its own is already quite interesting
since Gloom has the opposite effect on
humans it saps their life force making
them feel sick and drained of energy
we've seen in breath the wild that
malice is not only harmful to the touch
but that it can also act as a kind of
fuel as seen with the Guardians my
running theory is that the monsters
inside the depths are mining zoneite in
service of Ganondorf more specifically
to Aid in his Revival the game makes it
clear that Ganondorf is gathering his
strength so he can be restored to his
former self and since zonaid can act as
a power source when processed it's
possible that his monster squad is
gathering energy to help speed up his
restoration fueled by his Gloom and
never stopping to take a break and since
we're on the topic of gatendorf there's
a stone monument inside the previously
unseen basement of Hyrule castle that
explains why the castle was built there
in the first place it states that its
initial construction is closely tied to
upholding the seal on the Demon King to
make sure that nobody would disturb his
underground tomb and release him from
his chains be it on purpose or
accidentally which as we all know still
ends up happening eventually and I guess
was bound to happen at some point either
way I find it interesting that back when
the castle was built its primary
function was not to display the hylian's
power and dominance or because it was a
strategic location to put it but to
essentially serve as a sort of cork
sealing off the underworld and keeping
ganondorf's existence hidden if not for
Ganondorf the castle may have been
constructed somewhere completely
different maybe on the great plateau
for the final piece of lore we're going
back to the surface to the original
zonai ruins the OG location that started
the whole Zone I crazed long before we
knew anything about the sequel to breath
of the wild and its story for the sake
of spoilers I won't say which part of
the story this takes place in or what
the goal is but at some point we're
supposed to visit the zonai ruins to
help solve a mystery however before you
do one of the researchers investigating
the history of the zonai called Caleb
shares a pretty big bombshell with us
back at kakuriko Village he states that
the zonai ruined situated in fahren
actually predate the ruins that fell
from the sky I won't go too deep into
the implications here because that's a
topic that can easily take up a video of
its own but safe to say this is a pretty
big Revelation it's implied that at
least some of the ruins we find in the
sky are part of the original zonai
civilization the ones who first
descended onto Hyrule long before rauru
before Ganondorf before any of the
events we see happening in the past for
example a construct on bravery Island
tells the story of how young zonai
Warriors used to partake in skydiving
contests here as part of their
transition into adulthood meaning this
island existed back when the zonai were
still plentiful by the Time Zelda
arrives in the ancient past it's told
that the Zone I have already left the
surface a long time ago everyone except
raru and his sister they are the last of
the zonai at this point in time or at
least the last ones who reside on the
surface the idea that the ruins in
farron are even older than the ones
found in the sky has so much potential
for theories and speculation because by
all accounts it could mean that they
were built before the zonai ever even
set foot in Hyrule and thus may not even
be of zonai making but rather built by a
different faction who lived on the
surface before the zonai's arrival it
would explain why some of the
quote-unquote zonai architecture on the
surface is so different from the ones
found in the sky and in hyrule's
Underworld aside from the dragon Motif
it's not even close when you really put
these two side by side I intend to make
a future video on this topic so for now
I will leave it at that so I can work it
out into something bigger I'd like to
say thank you all so much for watching
and it's good to be back making Zelda
videos again my apologies if my voice
sounded a bit different I'm coming down
with the worst case of hay fever I've
had in a long time so yeah anyway I hope
you continue to have a good time with
the game I know I will and I will see
you all next time
foreign
[Music]
thank you